Uh,
that's exactly the symbolism of the great side.
All hierarchy to,
to power.
Okay.
And selfish power.
Is it is utterly naive.
It's ignorant,
right?
So I say education has to be totally reconstituted it,
including public education to be getting the most distant path so that show our
young people today who know nothing about how the,
how the world was created that they inhabit.
Okay.
Because understand,
okay,
what marvelous paradise they live in.
And it's the product of capitalism is the product we're probably going to
individual innovation is the most of,
is the product of a,
of a Western tradition that everyone wants to trash.
Now is there,
if you'd be good in the past and show it off to talk about war and because the
war is the one thing that wakes people up.
Okay.
As we see right?
Wars.
Yes.
Okay.
Wars.
The reality principle.
My,
I'm father and all five of my uncles went to World War II.
You know,
in my,
you know,
my father was w was part of the,
the force that have landed in Japan.
Okay.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
it has him,
he was a paratrooper.
Um,
you know,
at the,
at the time of the Japanese surrender.
Okay.
And,
and,
and a couple of uncles got shot up and so on.
When you have the reality of war,
when people see the reality of the horrors of war,
Berlin burned to a crisp and and so on or you,
your starvation.
Okay.
Then you understand,
okay,
this is marvelous mechanism that brings water,
you know,
to the,
to the kitchen.
And when you do flip on a light late in the electricity,
the electricity,
I know for me like I suppose it's because I have somewhat of a depressive
temperament.
I mean,
one thing that staggers me on a consistent basis is the fact that anything ever
works.
I mean,
because it's so unlikely,
you know,
to,
to be in a situation where our electronic communications work,
where our,
where our electric grid works and it works all the time.
Right?
It works 100% of the time.
And the reason for that is that there are mostly men out there who are breaking
themselves into pieces repairing this thing,
which just falls apart all the time.
I said this in the moment
bait.
Okay?
In Toronto several years ago,
I said that,
and I,
this is the invisible at all these,
these,
you know,
and he's elitist professors,
snaring and men.
It's men who are maintaining everything around us or anything.
This is an invisible army.
Okay?
Which are you?
What your feminists don't notice,
right?
Nothing would work
or regarded regardless.
Impressive.
Which is,
you know,
like a professor is someone who's standing on a hill surrounded by a wall,
which is surrounded by another wall,
which is surrounded by another wall.
Like it's walls all the way down.
Who stands up there and says,
I'm brave and independent.
It's like,
you've got this protected area that's so unlikely.
It's so absolutely unlikely.
And the fact that people aren't on their knees in gratitude all the time for the
fact that we have central heating and air conditioning and Ken pure water and
reliable food,
it's just,
it's so,
it is.
It's absolutely unbelievable.
People used to die for,
then the water supply was contaminated with,
for heaven's sakes.
Right?
People don't understand.
Okay.
Then I had clean water,
fresh milk,
fresh orange juice,
all of these things.
There's a moral goals,
the time,
all the time that,
that w western culture is,
is heading.
Okay.
It can be,
because we are so dependent on this,
on this invisible infrastructure where a heading for an absolute catastrophe,
when do hottest figure out how to paralyze the power grid.
The entire culture will be chaotic.
You'll have mobs in the street.
Okay.
And within three days.
Window.
And so suddenly the food supplies interrupted and there's no link.
There's no,
no way to communicate.
There'll be like the Robert,
I mean that that is the way western culture is going to collapse.
Okay.
And it won't take much.
You'll just,
because we are so interconnected and now we are.
So it's so,
it's so dependent on communications and computers into the,
I've,
I used to predict for years there'll be an asteroid hitting the earth and you
have enough,
the solar flares work.
So back in,
this happens about once every century.
So back about 1880 and I don't remember the exact year,
there was a significant enough solar flare,
so that produces an electromagnetic pulse like a hydrogen bomb because the sun
is a hydrogen bomb and electromagnetic pulse will emerge from the sun and wave
across the earth and it produces huge spikes in electrical,
uh,
electrical current along anything that's electronic and he'll burn them out.
It led it lip telegraph operators on fire in the 18 hundreds and one of those
things took out the Quebec power grid in 1985 and knocked out the whole
northeast corridor.
And so they figured those things are about one in new century event.
But those single,
I have my brother in law who's a very smart guy.
He designed the chip in the iPhone.
We were talking about political issues the last time I went and saw him in San
Francisco.
And his notion was that all that the government should be doing right now is
stress testing our infrastructure the same way they stress test the banks
because we're so full of these single points of failure that,
and I think you're absolutely right.
Luckily we've been,
um,
what would you call,
invaded by stupid terrorists instead of smart terrorists?
Because it's a smart terrorist could do an unbelievable amount of damage in a
very short period of time.
So when it's just God's good graces that that hasn't happened yet.
And so,
and then what will happen is that if the men,
okay,
the men will reconstruct civilization while the women cower in the houses.
And I have the men go out and do all the dirty work.
That's what's going to happen again.
Only men will,
will bring civilization back again.
Yeah.